hi everyone jerry Gianna's here really
excited to announce the release of the
Omega reflector it's been a while the
making but it's finally been released
and you might ask what is the Omega
reflector and how does it differ to
other ones in the market quite simply it
is the world's first ten in one shoots
four reflector it really is to create
beautiful gorgeous beauty lighting it
really combines the traditional nature
of a reflector with a luxury of a beauty
dish and a ring flash so I want to walk
through some examples and actually show
you exactly why I created it and what
it's useful so let me show you an
example here this is actually a
photograph a behind-the-scenes
photograph of Melissa facing a wall
where the Sun is illuminating it so for
years now since at the beginning of my
career twenty-one years ago I as
everyone does
I guess everyone uses you know walls as
natural reflectors perhaps a slightly
different way or a subtly different way
that I use walls is that I often get my
subjects in this case Melissa here my
wife I got her close to that wall so the
sunlight is giving her a beautiful back
and hair light it's bouncing off the
wall and then giving her this beautiful
soft gorgeous Beauty lighting from the
front so that's the behind-the-scenes
now just so you know I was actually
standing around about here shooting this
way and this is the result that I get
okay so you can see how the lighting is
beautifully soft it's less descriptive
and it's just that some of em you light
shooting through a softbox quite simply
it is we've created that with the Sun
but we've given two qualities of Lies or
two directions I guess because you've
got the hair in the back light and then
you've got the front light like I said
less descriptive beautiful lighting very
flattering and you can't see much
texture in the skin and so on and so
forth but there is a a shadow on the
face now typically sort of beauty
lighting you want to get rid of all
those shadows because it's like filling
in the the Grand Canyon of crevices on
your face and basically you don't see
any texture or a little texture so
because I've been doing this for all
these years I thought look what happens
when you don't have a wall and you want
that front
light and you don't want any kind of I
guess evidence of a direction I want
soft beauty lighting less descriptive
beautiful catch lights in the eyes what
do I do
so I embarked on a journey to create a
really easy way of creating this kind of
lighting and very affordably so I did
some tests
I got various reflectors and I cut them
out and I had some fun of it I've gone
through like dozens of reflectors to
work out the right hole size the ratio
the distance between the end of the hole
and the end of the reflector and then
finally this was born so what I've done
here is you can as you'd appreciate the
sunlight is hitting the back of her
hitting the reflector and now I have
this perfect position to shoot through
and then get this kind of result so guys
this shot that you're seeing right in
front of you on my wife melissa was the
very first test that i did of the omega
reflector i guess the the birth of it
and what i saw this shot come out of my
camera with very little shadow beautiful
catch lights in the eyes beautiful hair
and rim light i'm thinking you know what
i think this is worth exploring a little
in a lot more detail the problem was
with the reflectors that i test that i
cut the holes out of my existing
reflectors first of all I ruined my
reflector so I couldn't use it as a
normal reflector again and then it
started fraying on me and then I
struggled with the the right proportion
of the hole and the distance between the
edge of the hole on the end of the
reflector and all those different things
and then finally it
I found the results now as you may or
may not know I actually invented the eye
slide and has been made in conjunction
with Westcott a great company that's
really believes in continuous lighting
in my humble opinion a couple of years
ago and i teamed up with them again to
create the Amega reflector so i want to
talk to you about exactly what it is so
i don't know about you guys but i've
actually for years now i've found it
very difficult to get the reflector out
of my shot you know you know when you go
to your assistant and you're holding the
lights down and you always want the
position what weather reflector is and
so here now the whole offers a perfect
opportunity to actually shoot through
and of course it also masks the flare of
the sun on your lens which of course I'm
sure you've actually struggled to
actually to hide or mask over the years
so what's happening in this particular
shot has he Dupree
the sun's in the back of her head it's
shining on the reflector over here and
then coming back on her face now let's
look at the before and after example in
this next example that so this shot is
without the megareflector this is a
beautiful girl but a beautiful girl in
poor light doesn't shine as bright as
you'd appreciate now looking at the shot
on the right-hand side
the Sun hits her back of her head
beautiful hair and rim light hits the
the reflector back on her face gorgeous
catch lights in the eyes that make the
eyes pop and it just gives you this
beautiful beauty lighting now guys this
is not a lighting product that's going
to solve all your problems this I would
simply say it's this it's a traditional
reflector that you can use in any way
you know what a fireman one is right a
five in one is normally where it's a
black site on one side white site on the
other then you inverse it you've got
gold and silver and then internally you
have the translucent diffuser where
light travels through but you can't see
through it so it's exactly that plus the
fact is that we get five more options to
be able to shoot through it and get that
non-descriptive Beauty lighting so the
extra element that we've added with this
particular product is like I said you
get this beautiful soft gorgeous
lighting that's very quick and easy and
very transportable and portable and you
can take with you on location let me
show you a few more things that you may
want to look at now guys let me show you
something here now what I've got here
just want to show you here I'm actually
showing you a raw file this is straight
from the camera I've deliberately shot
this girl
deliberately to not be that flattering
this is overcast lighting so the
lighting is basically you would say it's
one big softbox but there is a direction
as it appreciate you can see that the
Sun is behind the clouds there of course
and it's coming from the top you can see
evidence of that because the lighting is
coming from their forehead on her
cheekbones and cheekbones and her nose
so really it's an unflattering quality
of light I don't know about you but I've
seen a huge trend over the last year or
two for that many of the new generation
are actually backlighting everything and
that's totally ok as long as in my
opinion there is a direction of lighter
or an arid essence of the skin or a
saturation
of the skin from the front because
backlighting is one thing but
backlighting and beautiful front lights
is another so like I said you are
looking at a raw file if you look at the
texture of his skin this is a beautiful
girl devynn one of our closest friends
but you can see how you can see the you
know the skin texture and so on now
let's now show you a behind-the-scenes
image so as it appreciate being a real
file as you can see there the lighting
is basically hitting the reflector back
on her and it gives us a perfect
position to shoot her and this is the
result strata to camera no Photoshop not
even a JPEG exported from Lightroom
that's corrected this is a raw file and
you can see now the difference between
that one and the one previously in fact
let me put them side-by-side
so side by side you can see it's a huge
difference these are raw files left-hand
side Noah megareflector right-hand side
with the megareflector let's zoom them
up a little bit and you'll see the
difference and I struggle to find any
other quicker and easier more effective
and more affordable way to get that kind
of lighting sort of straight a camera
like I said guys this is not going to be
the answer to all your lighting needs
but it'll certainly answer a lot of them
in a lot of different ways all right
let's have a look at another girl here
okay so here we see again this is a raw
file taking trailer camera beautiful
girl but the lighting is pretty poor you
know you'd see that this should I want
to hunt them if their eyes they're the
light you submit uneven on her face but
there's some beautiful backlight and
hair light there fantastic no problem so
let's look at the behind the scenes shot
here again this is a real farm you're
seeing now straight away you can see her
skin just glow and pop it looks amazing
and then we see the after shot and a
huge difference
let's go closer to the skin so you can
see what's going on look at the catch
lights in her eyes the roundness of the
corners of the of the Omega reflector
you would say soften the nature that
it's square and it mirrors somewhat the
the roundness of her eye so it really
brings attention to the pupil of the eye
it surrounds the the the the pupil it's
it just really brings attention to that
to those eyes I love that I love the ice
it's beautiful
all right so let's keep on going let's
show you some more examples here to show
you what we're talking about this shot
again guys this is actually a real file
it's a straight outta camera what I did
was I shot this recently in during my
how-to out so that some of you may have
attended in the US and what's happened
here is I've actually put some Christmas
lights or feral items we call them in
Australia in the background for bit of
ambience exposed for that ambience and
then we've added a speedlight behind her
the speed light gives her that beautiful
little glow around the edges of her hair
it's the reflector back bounces back on
her face again for a very nondescript be
utilizing which i think is great so
all right there now let me sort of show
you a few more ways to use this
particular reflector so it's not limited
to using a speed light or outdoors of
the Sun it's in many different ways now
Lisa again as you may have seen her just
there before I actually noticed sunlight
coming right through a hotel hallway so
I grabbed Lisa brought her down on the
carpet there the sunlight hits the
reflector then goes back on her face and
as you can see we've got beautiful
gorgeous catch lights in the eyes and
nondescript lighting there as well and
as you can see without the reflector
it's just it's just nothing you just
wouldn't photograph there so let me show
you some more examples here so this one
here is just using ordinary window light
so as you can see on this particular
section we've got beautiful hair light
here rim light here beautiful but her
face there's nothing going on there you
could fix it up afterwards in Photoshop
you can spend time bringing up some
catch lights in the eyes you can spend
time dodging and burning her face but
with the Omega reflector all the sudden
is this beautiful glow as you can see on
her face Gore does catch lights and then
we have the behind the scenes
photographs right at the camera for you
to see exactly the difference between
with the reflector or without it all
right let's move on to another example
so here I photograph this girl in open
shade as you know open shade offers a
very cool sort of unflattering quality
of life there's really not much
direction of light so what I simply did
here is in my app dual studio in my home
in LA I've got a speedlight the Nikon
speed light 9/10 and then I bounce the
speed light off the reflector back on
her giving us a beautiful hair light and
then goddess front light and you can
even see from this far away how amazing
those the eyes pop so look at the
difference between that quality of light
on the right and on the left and it's
amazing like I said if if perhaps you're
doubting whether this is valid because
maybe the image on the right hand side
has been retouched I show you those RAW
files straight from the camera before
and it's it's incredible quite simply it
just gives
it brings you closer to the end product
then then perhaps without using it or in
different ways you know if you if you
love beauty lighting and you want
gorgeous quality of light less
descriptive this is the reflector for
you if you want a normal reflector then
use it as a normal reflector as well so
it is all beautiful okay guys here's
another example so what I did was I if
people ask me all the time can can we
shoot a full body or a full length well
quite simply it depends
and if you go closer to the hole with a
wider angle lens certainly as you can
see you can photograph in the you know
3/4 or full length but you need this
sweet spot of light to hit the reflector
back on her here what I've got is of
course this shot the top left hand side
there is no reflector at all it's
ambient light you might ask you what is
the one of those horrible shadows on the
wall that's actually just the the
ambient sort of chandelier light that's
causing those shadows there that's
partly affecting the ambience of that
light so here now we've got the speed
light bounces off the reflector back on
here and as you can see you get that
beautiful lighting with less shadows and
it works really well
typically guys I actually personally
love dramatic shadows I love the idea of
drama and adding sort of highlights and
shadows to my images that gives it depth
but this is a different quality of light
this is a this is a beauty life this is
again like I said a combine the nature
of the traditional reflector with a ring
flash and a beauty dish alright let's
look at this next example so I'm sure if
you've ever use big light and I'm sure
you have you will often under expose the
sky and then add your flash and then you
under expose the ambience it keeps your
attention on the person so this image
here on the top left hand side is just
photographing this girl with nothing no
no just normal flat overcast lighting
and the sun's gone behind the clouds
there and that's basically what I've
done here is I've under exposed the sky
and under expose my background so you
can see how the part of the trees where
I was photographing into there I've just
gone darker and then I've got the speed
light there behind her giving her a
beautiful hair lights hitting the
reflected and back on her and again for
a very less descriptive easy lighting
let me show you a few more
examples here now guys really excited I
know these sounds will be funny but I
believe this is also the first reflector
ever to include a suction cup if you're
anything like me sometimes I shootin
receptions or homes where it's all glass
or all mirrors now if you've ever
bounced through a flash off a roof off
er an actual window or a mirror you know
that it actually just looks horrible so
quite simply put the suction cup on the
window then you have something to bounce
off or in this case if you have the sun
shining through a window and it's just
really harsh and you want to soften it
and make create that window to be a
softbox rather than have your assistant
hold it suction cup this suction cup
there on the on the glass and now you
have this big soft box this big
beautiful diffused glow of light on her
face and it works really well some
people didn't tell their fantastic now I
have a hook or a suction cup I can hang
the dress because I would do a detail
shot of the dress and I can hang it on
the glass window and of course you can
do that as well so fantastic now if you
want to basically take all the holes out
of it as in take the velcro panels off
the reflector the three panels now you
can create shafts of light with it this
is just one example of course but you
can imagine with the angle of the Sun
and the angle of the reflector you can
get incredible little shafts of light or
you can do pretty much anything you want
to so here we have an example that I
showed you bit earlier perhaps a bit
more behind-the-scenes detail of this so
I found some Christmas lights or some
fairy lights in my in my environment
this shot here was shot of about twelve
thousand eight hundred ISO just so you
can see what the quality of light was on
her then we put one speed light behind
her it gives us that beautiful hair
light hits the reflector back on her
face and then now we get that gorgeous
lighting as well by the way before I
forget just so you know the reflector
also comes with a strap I don't know
about you but when I've used a reflector
in the past its I had to hold the
reflector between my legs underneath my
chin underneath my armpit it comes with
a loop of course like it all reflectors
do but I simply also added a strap to
the reflector so it actually works well
if you're anything like me guys I'm sure
you've used your diffuser your your
panel inside your fiving one reflector
that the the one-stop diffusion panel
diffuser as a somewhat of a soft box
where you can shine a speed light
through it and then it just becomes this
soft box if you want a smaller smaller
window per se put the black side on the
around the reflector and then you have
this smaller panel to shoot through but
not sure the part of me where the light
actually illuminates through and now
it's a bit more dramatic so think of it
like photographing with a small window
light as opposed to a bigger window life
and there's so many different
combinations that you can use with this
reflector as well
now guys of course you can use it as a
normal reflector you know just keep the
panels on velcro them on and of course
this is just using window light as you
can see here and this is just signing
the roof this is no reflector this is
just using ordinary window light coming
right through and now we have the
behind-the-scenes this is using the
silver side if you want something a bit
sharper and contrast here sunlight side
if you want something warmer by the way
most reflectors come with a gold side
and if anything like me the gold side I
never use because it's just simply too
gold to warm and it makes all your
subjects of like Rumble numbers so we've
made its sunlight and we call it
sunlight it's a combination of silver
and and and gold so it gives you this
beautiful soft warm glow without being
too warm this is using the white side
and of course this isn't using the black
side so people are often asked me guys
what do I use the black side of
reflector for of course a black star
doesn't reflect it cuts away light
people call it a gobo or a cutter in
layman's terms I call it a cutter it
cuts away the light so you can compare
the difference between this shot in the
bottom right and this one on the top
left it cuts away the light reflecting
off the opposing wall and back on her
face for a more dramatic dense shadows
and it gives you a lot of different I
love as well so alright let's look at
this example this is what using the
cutter outdoors so this is without the
cutter so basically this is just like
bouncing off this world in fact giving
the giving you sort of a nice sort of
warm glow but then I've got the
reflector that cuts away light giving
you a more dramatic quality and it just
offers more of a direction of
you almost feel the lighting is coming
from this direction now which of course
it is because we're cutting away the
light from this particular side also
guys have you ever wanted to photograph
through a piece of reflective glass or
something and then all you're seen is
this horrible you know this horrible
roof reflection off a car so what we
simply do is this you you block out the
light the reflection in the direction of
where the lights coming from there so in
other words if I'm shooting in this
particular way all I'm seeing is what's
happening on the other side if you draw
that sort of that little angle there if
I cut away that reflection now I see
vividly through that piece of glass now
guys this is nothing innovative you
could use a black jacket you can use
your existing reflector I'm just showing
you many ways you can use a non
reflector in case anyone listening out
there is perhaps less experienced or or
doesn't really know how to use a
reflector all right guys so I really
hope you enjoy that little mini tutorial
I guess
remember it is a reflector it's portable
it's 44 inches in its in its length and
it's a 44 45 inches part of me by 38
inches and it just gives you that
beautiful quality of light I really hope
you enjoy it and if you have some
examples jump on the Facebook page the
megareflector Facebook page and share
your photographs and give us give your
fellow photographers and other peers
many many ideas on how to use reflector
enjoy guys thank you